it is july 6 2022 and you're watching
the code report one of the most profound
quotes about the javascript ecosystem
comes from an old british guy who said
out of intense complexities intense
simplicities emerge at the time nobody
knew what the hell he was talking about
but in 2022 it's clear he was
prophesizing the rise of a new
javascript runtime called bun that's
right you no longer need node.js or dino
so go ahead and uninstall those from
your system right now bun just announced
its first beta release and makes the
claim that it's significantly faster
than node or dino not just a little bit
faster but orders of magnitude faster
it's always a good idea to be skeptical
about benchmarks provided by the creator
of a tool but as you can see here it's
about three times faster when server
rendering react running database queries
or executing native code with foreign
functions impressive
very nice
but what i'm more excited about is what
this tool can do to simplify your life
as a developer we'll get into that in
just a minute but first i know my mom is
going to ask me what a javascript
runtime is in the first place you can
think of javascript like gasoline it's
dangerous and bad for the environment
and by itself isn't very useful to make
javascript or gasoline useful it needs
to run through an engine to convert it
into raw energy or machine code for a
cpu the most popular javascript engine
is google's v8 which powers chrome node
and dino and makes javascript execution
extremely fast with just in time
compilation now gasoline combined with
an engine still isn't very useful the
average person wants that engine in a
car with user-friendly apis like wheels
file system access subwoofers websockets
automatic transmission and so on a
javascript runtime is a complete car all
you have to do is put a little bit of
javascript in the tank and it will take
you anywhere you want to go now that
we're done with that ridiculous analogy
let's talk about what makes bun special
a big one is obviously performance but
how does it actually go so fast well
first of all it doesn't use the v8
engine but instead uses javascript core
from webkit which is generally
considered to be faster but more
difficult to work with in addition it's
written in a low level programming
language called zig this is a relatively
new language that's similar to c or rust
and the creators of bun say the lack of
hidden control flow makes it much
simpler to write fast software it's fun
to go fast but more importantly bun is
an all-in-one runtime it has a native
bundler to replace tools like webpack
and also has a native transpiler so you
can write typescript code out of the box
with cool features like top level await
an idea that's already been pioneered by
dino but bun will also transpile your
jsx files also like dino it prioritizes
web apis like fetch while at the same
time also supporting many node core
modules as well as node api which will
allow many npm packages to also work in
bun in fact it implements node's module
resolution algorithm which means you can
install packages from npm into bun and
those packages install 20 times faster
it feels like magic another nice
ergonomic feature is that environment
variables load automatically it's not
like node.js where you have to install
env into every project it also comes
with its own test runner similar to jess
and as you might imagine it's fast some
might even call it blazingly fast sounds
awesome but keep in mind this project is
in its infancy there will be bugs if
you're on windows you'll have to use wsl
and even that gave me some issues but
overall my final analysis on bun is that
this thing is bussin no cap for real
this has been the code report thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one